des choses remarquables se produisent.
En partant pour un voyage en avion,
j'ai été témoin d'un incident
dans lequel un passager a essayé de monter à bord
avant qu'on l'appelle,
et j'ai regardé l'agent à l’embarquement
traiter cet homme comme s'il avait enfreint la loi,
comme un criminel.
On lui a crié dessus pour avoir essayé de monter à bord
un groupe trop tôt.
J'ai dit quelque chose.
J'ai dit, « Pourquoi nous traitez-vous comme du bétail ?
Pourquoi ne pas nous traiter comme des êtres humains ? »
Et voilà ce qu'elle m'a répondu.
Elle a dit, « Monsieur, si je ne respecte pas les règles,
je pourrais avoir des ennuis et perdre mon emploi. »
Ce qu'elle était en train de me dire
est qu'elle ne se sentait pas en sécurité.
Ce qu'elle était en train de me dire c'est
qu'elle n'avait pas confiance en ses dirigeants.
La raison pour laquelle nous aimons la Southwest Airlines
n’est pas qu'elle embauche nécessairement de meilleures personnes.
C'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas peur de leurs dirigeants.
Vous voyez, si les conditions sont mauvaises,
nous sommes obligés de dépenser notre temps et notre énergie
pour nous protéger l'un de l'autre,
et ça affaiblit l'organisation implicitement.
Quand nous nous sentons en sécurité à l'intérieur de l'organisation,
nous combinons naturellement nos talents
et nos points forts et travaillons inlassablement
pour faire face aux dangers extérieurs.
et saisir les opportunités.
L'analogie la plus proche que je puisse vous donner
à un grand leader, est celle d'un parent.
Réfléchissez à ce que signifie être un bon parent,
que voulez-vous ? Qu'est ce qui fait un grand parent ?
Nous voulons offrir à nos enfants des opportunités,
une éducation, de la discipline si nécessaire,
pour qu'ils puissent grandir et accomplir
plus que ce que nous avons fait.
Les grands leaders veulent exactement la même chose.
Ils veulent offrir des opportunités à leurs employés,
une éducation, de la discipline si nécessaire,
développer leur confiance en soi, leur offrir des opportunités
d'essayer et échouer,
pour qu'ils puissent réussir
plus que ce que nous imaginons pour nous-mêmes.
Charlie Kim, le PDG d'une société qui s'appelle Next Jump
à New York, une société tech,
explique que,
si vous aviez des difficultés en famille,
envisageriez-vous de laisser tomber un de vos enfants ?
Jamais.
Alors, pourquoi envisager de laisser tomber
des personnes de votre organisation ?
Charlie a appliqué une politique
d'emploi à vie.
Si Next Jump vous embauche,
vous ne pouvez pas vous faire virer pour des problèmes de performances.
En fait, si vous avez des problèmes,
on vous aide et on vous soutient,
comme on ferait avec les enfants
qui rentrent à la maison avec un 9/20.
C'est tout le contraire.
C'est la raison pour laquelle de nombreuses personnes
ont une telle haine viscérale
pour certains PDG de banques
avec leurs salaires et bonus disproportionnés.
Ce ne sont pas les chiffres.
Ils ont violé la définition-même du leadership.
Ils ont violé ce profond contrat social.
Nous savons qu'ils ont permis que leurs employés
soient sacrifiés pour qu'ils puissent protéger leurs intérêts,
ou pire, ils ont sacrifié leur personnel
pour protéger leurs intérêts.
C'est ce qui nous indigne, ce ne sont pas les chiffres.
Quelqu'un s'indignerait-il si nous offrions
un bonus de 150 millions de dollars à Gandhi ?
Et si nous offrions 250 millions de dollars à Mère Teresa ?
Ça nous pose problème ? Pas du tout.
Pas du tout.
Les grands leaders ne sacrifieraient jamais
les gens pour sauver les chiffres.
Ils sacrifieraient d'abord les chiffres
pour sauver les personnes.
Bob Chapman gère
une grande société de production dans le Midwest
qui s’appelle Barry-Wehmiller,
En 2008 elle a été durement touchée par la récession,
et ils ont perdu 30 pour cent de leurs commandes d'un jour à l'autre.
Pour une grande société,
c'est un gros problème,
et ils ne pouvaient plus se permettre leur main d'œuvre
Il leur fallait économiser 10 millions de dollars,
donc, comme beaucoup de sociétés,
le conseil s'est rassemblé pour discuter des licenciements.
Et Bob a refusé.
Bob ne croit pas au nombre de personnes.
Il croit au nombre de cœurs,
et c'est beaucoup plus difficile de réduire
le nombre de cœurs.
Ils ont élaboré un programme de congés.
Chaque employé, de la secrétaire au PDG,
devait prendre quatre semaines de congés non payés.
Ils pouvaient les prendre quand ils voulaient,
et ils ne devaient pas les prendre tous d'affilés.
Mais c'est comme ça que Bob a annoncé le programme
qui avait tant d'importance.
Il a dit, il vaut mieux souffrir tous un peu
plutôt que quelqu’un ait à souffrir beaucoup,
et le moral est remonté.
Ils ont économisé 20 millions de dollars,
et surtout, comme prévu,
quand les gens se sentent en sécurité
et protégés par la direction de l'organisation,
la réaction naturelle est la confiance et la collaboration.
Assez spontanément, sans qu'on s'y attende,
les gens ont commencé à faire des échanges entre eux.
Ceux qui pouvaient en prendre plus
les échangeaient avec ceux qui pouvaient moins se le permettre.
Certains prenaient cinq semaines
pour que d'autres puissent n'en prendre que trois.
Le leadership est un choix. Ce n'est pas un grade.
Je connais des gens au plus haut niveau
des organisations
qui ne sont absolument pas des leaders.
Ce sont des autorités, et nous faisons ce qu'ils disent
parce qu'ils ont de l'autorité sur nous,
mais nous ne les suivrions pas.
Et je connais beaucoup de gens
qui sont au plus bas niveau des organisations
qui n'ont aucune autorité
et sont des leaders absolus,
et ce parce qu’ils ont choisi de s'occuper
de la personne à leur gauche,
et ils ont choisi de s'occuper
de la personne à leur droite.
Voici ce qu'est un leader.
J'ai entendu l'histoire
de certains Marines
qui étaient au théâtre,
et comme le veut la coutume dans la Marine,
l'officier mange en dernier,
et il laisse ses hommes manger en premier,
et quand ils avaient fini,
il n'y avait plus rien à manger pour lui.
Et quand ils sont revenus sur le terrain,
ses hommes lui ont ramené de la nourriture
pour qu'il puisse manger,
parce que ça se passe comme ça.
Nous les appelons des leaders parce qu'ils y vont en premier.
Nous les appelons des leaders parce qu'ils prennent le risque
avant les autres.
Nous les appelons des leaders parce qu'ils choisissent
de se sacrifier pour que d'autres
puissent être en sécurité et protégés
et leurs hommes puissent réussir,
et en faisant cela, la réaction naturelle
est que nos hommes se sacrifieront pour nous.
Ils verseront sang, sueur et larmes
pour voir naitre la vision de leurs leaders,
et quand nous leur demandons, « Pourquoi devrions-nous le faire ?
Pourquoi verser sang, sueur et larmes
pour cette personne ? » Ils répondent tous la même chose :
« Parce qu'ils feraient la même chose pour moi. »
N'est-ce pas l'organisation
dans laquelle nous souhaiterions tous travailler ?
Merci beaucoup.
Merci. (Applaudissements)